hi glamour i am jamie jennifer and
welcome to my beauty span
[Music]
so i first got interested in makeup um
not super early i don't have one of
those stories that's um
me going through my mom's makeup bag and
playing the makeup or anything i was
always
more of a tomboy i definitely started
playing with it
in my teenage my teen years uh i'm used
to going
to first parties and stuff i would sit
and play with my smokey eyes
at the moment yeah i think mascara and
lip liner
i eat easily i really like my makeup and
when i'm not got much time and i've
literally got time to do a little bit of
lip liner
and some mascara skin care spf
spf my favorite one at the moment is the
thank you farmer
as an spf 50 is so lovely and glowy
on the skin as well which i really like
i've definitely taken a razor
to my eyebrows when i was young
and my mum's razor i just remember
taking it and just gonna zoom
down the middle uh and obviously you
know this is not
a razor blades apart if you're wanting
to wear a lipstick then i would
definitely stay matte
uh i love wearing lipstick and lip liner
i wear it most days
and i've found that when wearing a mask
that if i use
a matte lip liner and a matte lipstick
definitely nothing glossy
then things don't tend to move around
too much and
to lock it in place don't be scared to
use a little bit of how you do
when it comes to feel safe rules
i don't really think that there's any
rules when it comes to makeup
i think as long as the wearer
feels confident and gorgeous and they
love it then i think
go forth and wear the makeup
i feel really lucky i've had a bloody
great time
um in the last year in lockdown i have
to say that um
it's so bittersweet because one of my
career highlights has been launching
fave which is
a makeup brand that i've dreamed of for
a really really long time
since i worked on makeup counters and
but all the travelling that me and jack
have been able to do together
has just been mind-blowing
[Music]
[Applause]
my first step is a bit of a multi-tasker
i have a low bunning so i'm going to
take my hair out
and i'm going to use the whey
fine to medium hair mask rub
and we're going to just start applying
to our hair
and then just secure with a bobble
i'm going to use my concealer this is
the nars radiant creamy concealer in the
shade
sucra george i'm going to use this to
conceal
and also use it forever i need just a
tiny bit of coverage
i've got a little blemish here see ya
and then i'm just going to
pat that out with a brush next step is
using
a eyeshadow stick for ease and
longevity these are the new ions by
vave which is my brand i am so excited
about these
this is the shade sand so if i pop it on
you'll see that it's
quite close to my skin tone but what
it's going to do is it's going to make
my eyes look super open and awake so i'm
just going to sketch that on
next tip for beautiful sunkissed skin
without the summer holiday is to use a
really warm bronzy blush so this is the
sunset blush
by vive in the shade piazza and i'm
going to use this
almost like a bronzer i love to apply my
blush super high on my cheekbones
i think nothing goes youthful complexion
more than freckles and this is the frick
noir by frick i'm gonna
enhance my natural freckle first and you
just get this product
just literally a wee dot
and it looks quite dark at first but as
soon as you get your finger and start
look at that last but not least is a
lip so this is the it's weave but you
can
you can't even read the logo anymore
this is the modern lip definer in the
shade black
so i'm gonna just go
i'm gonna do the same thing as well is
that not the quickest easiest
transformation i've ever seen
now to finish the lip off i just like to
add a tiniest little bit of lip balm
this is the
nars afterglow lip balm and the shade
clean cut which is just clear
i'll just put a little bit on there
there we have it that is my five minute
five ish tips makeup look
something super summery and wearable and
spring fresh and post
lock down ready
[Music]
i'm going to talk you through my my my
shelfie
this is sbf this is the one i mentioned
before the
sun project water sun cream spf 50
is so nice it's really hydrating and
my skin really likes it this is my skin
centicles hyaluronic acid intensifier
i have used a hyaluronic acid in my
routine
for at least over like a year and a half
and i just love the way it makes my skin
feel the key is which is something that
i've learned recently
you need to have kind of damp a damp
face before you put this on
and it holds over a thousand times its
weight in water
science this is the best dry shampoo
ever this is the living proof perfect
hair day dry shampoo i was literally
about to say this and it says on the
bottle
actually cleans hair eliminates oil
sweat and odor
this product this is probably my fourth
or fifth bottle of this
uh it's the daveness oil oil this is
the best hair oil ever it smells
incredible
it's not too heavy i've got quite dry
hair as well and it really hydrates the
ends of my hair i just really
really love it the psychic sisters have
this
wish mist that is geranium and
clementine
it says dreams fulfillment vision
and here it is here you can see here
i'll just spray
i hope you enjoyed yourself and
hopefully i'll see you soon
bye